I love McDonald's he finds a way to  bring it up in every episode so Filet O  Fish I'm not kidding to be the worst  item in all of fast food it is it has no  place not just on their menu it is no  place in fast food you think you're  better than the filet fish 100 I am  better nothing on the McDonald's menu  has a bun as perfect as the filet fish  but does it have its own bun it is a  soft bun it's a cheeseburger they sold  those buns  on Fridays in Lent when my mom didn't  feel like cooking we got fish sticks and  that [ __ ] thing reminds me of those  awful fish sticks well it sounds like  you have an issue with your mother not  McDonald's that's what it is yeah yeah  and I don't like this sandwich this is  his childhood trauma that you're blaming  on McDonald's